something evil is swallowing up this
place bit by bit
nobody ever believes things can get this
bad until it happens
ma'am it's too late but
there are people who can fight back
stick together
welcome to redfall Massachusetts where
the calm seas and sunny skies have been
eclipsed by a legion of vampires
redfall is a story driven shooter at its
heart which can be played single player
or co-op with up to four players
choose your hero each with their own
unique abilities and form the perfect
vampire slaying Squad to take back red
Falls haunted streets
at Arcane we make games where the world
itself is as important as the characters
with redfall we take an exciting step
forward building a lovingly detailed
open world to deliver our largest
setting ever
three inch of our open world is
carefully handcrafted and packed with
environmental storytelling
explore the streets of a quaint Island
Town
from the once bustling downtown to the
haunted forest to the decimated seaside
boardwalk and gorgeously detailed
landmarks
but it's not all danger all the time
there are safe places on the island
where you can rest up chat with
survivors and resupply
here we're at the fire station one of
your home bases
this is one place you'll receive
missions from survivors
there's something I need you to do the
Old Lighthouse in the bay it's been used
for over a century to keep boats away
from the coastline if we turn it back on
it's a warning to anyone trying to come
to redfall right now easy right
well the Lighthouse Keeper is a real
[__] joined up with those cultists
and took the damn lamp with them
the wall bird
here's a vampire known as the Shroud
shrouds blanket the area in darkness
disorienting their prey
they hurl lethal projectiles and can
even shift through the floor to avoid
damage
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
the lighthouse is back up but there's
more waiting for you taking down
vampires angers the vampire Gods who
will summon the Rook to take you down
foreign
let's transition to what you'll find
outside of the main story missions
there's so much waiting for you redfall
is filled with encounters that can pop
up anywhere like this Brewery that's
Fallen under cultist control save the
locals from being offered to the
vampires
like our past games you can approach a
mission in many different ways
always be ready to improvise
Remy uses her combat robot reborn to
help distract and eliminate the cultists
foreign
[Music]
everyone's safe let's move on
exploring redfall will take you beyond
the bounds of reality as you investigate
otherworldly psychic spaces to unravel
the vampire secrets
take this vampire Nest these deadly
layers change each time you step inside
Jacob sends out his Raven to tag the
enemies below Dev follows up with his
teleporter instantly closing the gap
come on
[Music]
to destroy a nest you have to take out
its heart and all of the vampires
willing to die to protect it
horrible way to die
foreign
now Escape The Nest before it comes
crashing down it'll collapse any second
nests aren't the only psychic spaces
you'll find dangerous pockets all over
the island it's all vampire Turf so
tread carefully
so
redfall won't truly be safe until the
vampires are wiped from the map outside
the main story another one of your
missions is to take back redfall
neighborhood by neighborhood
find safe houses hidden all over the
island and then work your way up to the
vampire controlling the neighborhood
to reclaim this neighborhood you'll have
to defeat a powerful vampire
called the siphon
whether you dive in Solo or with friends
each hero can take on any situation each
brings powerful unique abilities to the
fight and the upgrades you choose change
how they play
here Layla's lift ability can be
upgraded to launch teammates for
Airborne attacks upgrade Layla's
umbrella ability with bullet hail to
absorb enemy bullets and release the
energy back at them
there are many ways to customize your
hero's ability tree to match your
playstyle
let's get some light on the subject
let's hit on the Arsenal there's a wide
range of Weaponry for military gear to
new vampire slaying inventions from
shotguns to sniper rifles
well well
and of course there's also vampire
Stakes find these in the world to
customize your weapons
[Music]
when you reclaim significant sections of
redfall the last step is to face the
underboss who controls or used to
control that neighborhood
underbosses are powerful Elites of the
vampire Gods with their own unique
abilities like this one's Shield
prove yourself against the underboss
you'll receive a key of sorts a skull
that gets you one step closer to facing
the ultimate threat the vampire gods
thank you for visiting redfall and thank
you for all the support you've shown
Arcane throughout the years we sometimes
joke that our games can be tough to
define the one thing that's consistent
we make the kinds of games we love to
play and that's how redfall was born we
Blended everything we love here at
Arcane Austin immersive open worlds
unique and customizable heroes RPG and
FPS gameplay and of course our signature
storytelling and Rich World building
along with our spin on one of the most
classic monsters of all time vampires
it's been amazing to see how all of us
have pulled together to deliver our
vision for something new redfall is the
biggest most ambitious game we have ever
made our teams Dove head first into this
new opportunity and we can't wait for
you to experience redfall for yourself
thankfully you won't have to wait too
much longer red Falls coming on May 2nd
thank you again for joining us and we'll
see you soon in redfall here we go
thank you
foreign
[Music]